I'm here at six a district judge says
thousands of people who are waiting for
unemployment benefits have been waiting
too long in a court hearing today denis
judge Barry Breslow said the Department
of Employment training and
rehabilitation needs to make
improvements Joe Moller reports on what
is happening next so the Court believes
as conclusion of law that it has the
ability to move forward with this case
and does so judge Barry bezler was
taking action after a lawsuit against
dieter was filed in May over the lengthy
time pandemic unemployment assistant
payments are taking he is demanding the
department fix the backlog of claims and
to bring the first filers who have not
been paid to the front of the line
people are in this no-man's land where
they're being blocked from benefits in
either one so I'm hoping that the state
can come forward in ten days and educate
the court on steps it's made to unblock
that group of people he ordered the
suspension of non payments for reasons
outside of a person's failure to file a
weekly claim or income in eligibility
this issue surfaced as he cited some gig
workers such as ride share drivers he
thought should still be eligible while
still working the court understands that
dieter has been construing someone who
rotted drives for a rideshare program
ineligible if they don't completely
suspend their activities the court
believes that's an error payments for
those who have had benefits stopped are
supposed to see payments by July 28th
I'd love to see you know something done
William Ireland is a ride-sharing driver
he filed more than two months ago if
something will get his and other claims
not everything my claim still in
progress Joe Moller 8 news now the court
will hear how dieter is making
improvements next Thursday morning to